Aaron is in San Diego hi Aaron how are
you I'm okay a little fast how are you
Dave better than I deserve what's up
Alta mately I'm just trying to figure
out if I should so my my wife and I
should sell her vehicle so we are in
baby step two we have a hundred and
sixty thousand left of debt last month
yeah last month we started your program
we were at two hundred and one thousand
oh you're moving file then what's your
household end yeah we right now gross is
120 and so we take home about eight
thousand a month don't you and what is
the what's the debt on so I printed out
my every dollar budget I have 36 in
credit cards between my wife and I we
have 39 thousand combined and student
loans her car's 33 thousand left I have
a personal loan for fourteen thousand to
my dad he was able he loaned me ten
thousand to get out of my truck that I
was upside down in last month which was
why the big decrease of going from 201
to 160 and then we also of 38,000 it's a
hero loan which is we financed our solar
system and HVAC system through our
mortgage no more I know
okay there you go borrowing everything
yeah our house payment is 3500 a month
yeah and my wife runs a in-home day care
through at our home well there's um two
rules of thumb I use on the card I
answer your original question rule
number one is the total of your vehicle
should not equal more than half your
annual income the total value of your
vehicle and they don't you don't violate
that one the second question is can I be
debt-free everything but the house in
two years and keep the car if it's less
than
the annual income the answer that that
is no which means you do need sell a car
if the car was three thousand dollars in
debt it wouldn't move the needle on 160
but I would sell the car the other
problem you've got is you have a
ridiculously high house payment and
given your take-home pay and so you've
got that other stress so let me tell you
what I think I'm seeing are you guys
what 33 34 I
we're both thirty thirty okay you know
you're right around there took a while
give this you didn't do this overnight
so what's happened is you guys were
normal and you pretty much if you wanted
something you bought it that's correct
and that's the credit card debt that
originally it was a student loan then it
was the car then it was your truck and
then it was you know the the hero stuff
and all that I mean if we see something
you know if we can sign papers and
they'll give it to us we'll sign the
papers let's just buy it and you just
you know step by step layer upon layer
I've gotten yourself into a real a real
thing a gumbo here a real soup right I
mean this is a lot of stress on this you
guys are it's stressful
so the how long have you guys been
married we've been together or high
school sweethearts have been together
for 12 married for seven okay once you
guys started feeling this and it built
up I'm guessing three years ago probably
what's the effect on that marriage are
you guys okay
we we are now we're a lot better now
honestly so my dad in order to give me
the personal loan he said you guys are
going through SPU and and then I had to
buy a hoop II and then he paid down my
negative equity in my truck and in the
last two months it's been feel much
better okay so by having a game plan and
a direction that's not into the ditch it
took some of the stress off the
relationship that's good
that sort of Emily does so because
normally I mean I would have guessed six
months ago if that was three months ago
six or eight months ago y'all were
probably like sharing to me when we were
going through we buy killed each other I
mean it wasn't about you know
so what we want to do is that that's the
main thing is I want to make sure
marriage is okay because that's more
important than all this crap all this
stuff right and the second thing is
let's get the mess cleaned up because
this is no fun as fast as we can you
make decent money considering the whole
year in you make good money but
considering the whole you end you're
just decent so you have a medium-sized
shovel a large hole you know that kind
of a thing right so it's not like you
make 120 and yo ten you know it's pretty
substantial so yeah I would sell the car
I want to make sure she's emotionally on
board with that that we're gonna that
we're both saying we've had it we're
gonna do whatever it takes we're ready
to win and we know that we're not
driving junk cars the rest of our life
but for a period of time we gotta clean
this mess up have you cut up all the
credit cards they're all actually
changed all my credit card numbers told
everyone I lost them and then cut them
up and I got the new ones so there's no
more auto pays or anything on them very
good no smart and she yeah and then she
is on board she actually is the one that
wants to go forward with selling her car
okay I got an offer from a dealership at
twenty four thousand five hundred that's
a little slim I'm just saying you know
you're trying to run a race with
dragging an anchor mm-hmm and I don't
how can run another lap with the anchor
but I don't want to run two years of
laps or three years of laps of this
anchor so but yes that's too much of a
cut that's a that's a wholesale - number
that tells me that car if you private
sell at home Kelley Blue Book look it up
behind put it on Craigslist or something
it's probably gonna bring 27 28 okay
yeah we have it at 27 and the Kelley
Blue Book is 26 nine there we go and
then we have a thousand that's going to
be odd next month for our car payment
and registration that's a kind of
considering the twenty four five offer
plus the thousand dollars at save and
registration and car payment would be
close to a private party and just be
done with it or just hold out that's not
a bad consideration and plus the payment
is five hundred
yeah and so another month of payments is
another another two months of payments
is to get its olds another thousands so
that gets you there yeah yeah I think
your analysis is pretty good there I'm
probably I'm gonna do that in this case
but the thousand dollars is unusually
high and it's obviously a San Diego
California situation you know in
Tennessee our registration it's nowhere
near that's like 100 bucks or something
you know so we're at that hard so but
that changes the equation you're right
that's new information and I think I
like your analysis yeah I'm gonna take
it here's the thing the beautiful thing
about what you're doing the truck and
the car are gone those are very
emotional decisions because all your
friends see that you see that you feel
it and that that is showing your
commitment to all this change both of
you together and I just love it I really
predict you're gonna be fine you're
gonna do really really well and and you
know just keep digging on it keep
scratching on it and I'm my tip of the
hat to your dad for you know putting
some stipulations on his help which
actually gave you real help that's very
cool
Financial Peace University turn it
around for you guys you got this Aaron
it's going to be a tough two years and
then you're gonna be back in the green
again you're gonna be okay hey if I can
help you more you call me anytime